- It's time for our next
game, Tatscrewed, Tatscrewed.
(applause and cheering)
If you get a tattoo,
you have to be prepared
to live with it forever.
It's not gonna come off.
They have to burn it off with
lasers and it fuckin' hurts,
I'm told, but thanks
to the perfectly named
f**knobadtattoos Tumblr, we
learned that some of the people
who chose to get tattoos
have very poor judgment.
Comedians, I'll describe two awful tattoos
and for 250 points, you
let me know which one
you think is real.
Okay, first one.
Donkey Kong swinging off a man's nipple,
or Sonic the Hedgehog running
into a guy's butt crack.
(laughing and cheering)
(imitates ringing)
Emily.
- It is definitely Sonic
the Hedgehog running
into a guy's butt crack,
'cause that's my dad.
- Okay, let's find out.
No, Donkey Kong, awesome,
swinging off a man's nipple.
- Awesome, that's so great.
- That's a good one.
I'd get that.
- And I'd get the monkey as well.
(laughing)
- All right, next one.
Knuckle tattoos spelling out Sorry Mom,
or a tramp stamp reading I Hate You Dad.
(bell rings)
Tim.
- I think the second is
so sitting on the edge
of something that you
wouldn't say on telly,
that it has to be the first one.
S-O-Er-Er-E M-Uh-Uh-M, Sorry Mom.
- Okay, let's find out.
Let's find out.
Sorry Mom.
(applause)
I feel bad for the guy that's
got to get an HJ with Mom
on the hand.
Could you use the, actually
sorry's not any better.
Just skip this.
I'll do it.
- But actually that hand has YMOM on it.
- [Emily] Why Mom.
(laughing)
- Why, Mom?
Add a point to Tim Minchin.
All right, next one, a
lower back tattoo that says
Ass: It's What's For Dinner,
or an above the breasts tattoo that says
Stop Staring Bitches.
- [Both] Stop Starring.
- Well, okay, we'll get
to the bottom of this.
(bell rings)
Yes, Emily.
- An above the breasts tattoo that says
Stop Starring Bitches.
- Okay, let's find out.
Yes, so it does.
(groaning)
(applause)
- That is such a bad idea, oh, my god.
- Now, I like to think that these eyes
are judging you for bad spelling, but--
- Does this turn you on?
- Hold on, what are we looking at?
The nipples are below
the shirt line, are they?
- The think the nipples are
very below the shirt line.
- Listen, everyone knows that--
- Hey, are the eyes on the nipples?
- [All] No, no, no.
- [Rhys] Everyone knows
the nipples are the eyes.
That's weird.
- Stop Starring Bitches.
Stop Starring.
- How does one star, and is it--
- I'll tell you what, I
would give that one star.
That's how you one star.
(applause)
Next one, Fred Durst's head
above two crossed rifles,
or Dave Matthews nude on horseback?
(laughing)
(bell rings)
Ridin' along on a horseback.
- It's definitely Dave
Matthews nude on horseback.
- [Host] You think so,
okay, let's find out.
- [Rhys] Hold on, hold on.
- What?
(groaning)
- [Rhys] That's a shame.
(laughing)
(applause)
- Wild guess, they got
this tattoo for the nookie.
- Really, because I think
that tattoo would create
a Limp Bizkit.
(laughing)
- I was confused by the question.
I think it's unfair 'cause it wasn't clear
if the second one was Dave Matthews nude
tattooed on a horse's back.
(laughing)
Was it a besotted horse?
- It was a little unclear
in the presentation
but unfortunately--
- [Tim] It doesn't matter
anymore, does it, because--
- It really doesn't, because
right now what everyone's
thinking is I don't care which one it was,
I just wish it was not this one.
All right, last one, matching
thigh tattoos of Obama
and bin Laden, or a
Despicable Me ass tattoo.
(bell rings)
Tim.
- Oh, please let it be the first one,
but it's the second one.
- [Host] You think it's the second one?
- Yeah, oh god.
Oh I'm sorry, I'm so nervous.
We did it.
- I just want to remind
you want country you're in.
Show us.
- [All] No.
- Oh, my god.
Oh, my god.
- I know, it's gonna be okay.
I know, I know.
Tim, come here, I know,
I'm sorry, I know, I know.
I know, I don't know, Tim.
- I don't understand what they're trying,
it's good, people should have
more nuanced views these days.
Just a little balance sometimes.
- I got a Green Card for this.
(laughing and applause)
I'm not staying here.